tensions flaring between Nancy Pelosi
and progressive lawmakers such as
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes she voted
against last month's border aid bill the
speaker dismissing the influence of the
freshman Democrat and other freshmen
Democrats telling the New York Times
quote all these people have their public
whatever and their twitter world but
they don't have any following there are
four people and that's how many votes
they got if the left doesn't think I'm
left enough so be it we have to have a
solution not just a Twitter fight end
quote
heyo see she's firing back tweeting
quote I find it strange when members act
as though social media is not important
they set millions of dollars on fire to
run TV ads so people can see their
message
I haven't dialed four dollars once this
year and have more time to do my actual
job yet we'd rather campaign like it's
2008 what do you say Dana look I admire
her her fight right in the spice that
she brings to it you're talking about
AOC yeah but I also admire Nancy Pelosi
because she can count votes and if you
are in a deep a blue district and any
Democrats going to get elected in your
district then yes it is easier to be a
firebrand and a distort was easier to do
all of those things and speaker Pelosi
has a different responsibility in a
different role like a her job is to try
to keep the majority and to try to
figure out a way to do as many of the
things that Democrats want to do with
the reality that they live in and if
they continue to go the way that they
are those 31 districts in the house that
helped Nancy Pelosi become speaker again
could very easily flip back to being
Republican when President Trump is at
the top of the ticket bring in
Republicans back in because not as many
people vote in a midterm the other thing
is she did this interview speaker Pelosi
did an interview with Maureen Dowd in
the New York Times got a lot of
attention that's where these quotes come
from where she's saying that these guys
only only have their Twitter game but it
came in an interesting time because she
had just lost a fight within our caucus
but it wasn't from the left it was from
the middle but they said we have to vote
for this funding for the border so I
think that she's trying to be wise and I
think that I understand wanting to push
up against her but
if I had to put Pelosi's political
skills up against a OCS at this moment
for what they need I would if I were the
Democrats I'd say can't you guys just
work together because together they
could be quite powerful but I don't know
if it's possible well I just don't think
there's any way that Congress when
Alexander Casa Cortez is on the same
power game level as Nancy Pelosi and the
votes just clearly show that but Greg
yes what was interesting to me is that
there was a note of contempt in the way
that Pelosi spoke about yeah so media
and Twitter right and then you see this
punch back from AOC saying oh you're
living in 2000 and she's right what are
you so I enjoy this fight this is so
much fun the dams are going through a
similar convulsion the Republicans
experienced you know for three or four
years ago Trump rattled the party and he
rattled the party using the similar
tools which was social media and we all
thought it would not we didn't all think
it was crazy but we were laughing and
enjoying it and then he beat everybody
with it you know and I think AOC is a
chip off the old Trump I think she's a
she is you know has she knows how to how
to work it and and I think that they
could probably learn from that it does
bother me that she didn't vote for the
bill I mean that's kind of strange when
you accuse others of hurting migrant
children and then you deny their aid
that seems to suggest that maybe this is
a political cynical pact of theater on
her part when you you know maybe let
people suffer and die before cooperating
with the president kind of sad
all right so Jesse what I'm reminded of
is that John Boehner Paul Ryan I think
Paul Ryan just left if he couldn't
handle the freedom caucus the whole Tea
Party thing anymore okay see now dealing
with much the same dynamic cept it's not
the far right but it's the far left well
I think banners gotta have a glass of
cabin laughing at Nancy because he
thinks you know you think you have it
bad I don't think it's wine anymore
[Laughter]
she has four bomb throwers he had dozens
of Tea Party members starting in 2010 he
had him for many many years that made
his life hell overspending and the debt
ceiling and he
did his best to keep the beef behind
closed doors right Nancy
seems to keep having these public spats
and she's only got four little bomb
throwers and it's only been four months
and she's already had fights about
anti-semitism impeachment progressivism
and now the border funding thing yeah
the green New Deal and she would just be
much better served if she would let her
whip team handle the drama and ignore
them and now she's nicknamed him the
squad
she's elevating them in the media and I
think this is wrong but I do agree with
AOC you shouldn't diminish the power of
social media she doesn't dial for
dollars she can leverage that platform
very powerful and Nancy doesn't
understand that and I think she should
soon all right
so Katie what's interesting to me is I
think the people on the right are hoping
that there's a big rift and a big fight
right but I don't know that Alexandra
Casa Cortez is at the level that she
really could take on Nancy I mean
they're not hoping for it it's already
here and we're watching it play out and
that's the reason why Nancy Pelosi's
having to answer questions in every
interview about this new caucus of
people who've everyone's saying isn't
very powerful but if she's being asked
about it and having to comment on it and
having to every presidential candidates
to say if they believe the green New
Deal and Medicaid for all Medicare for
all guess who's driving that narrative
these four people I bet they wish they
could go back to the days of being on
the cover of Rolling Stone when Nancy
Pelosi was on the cover with Ilhan Omar
a bit a little bit more you know
cooperation then but this is to pass
right so Nancy Pelosi is doing what Dana
talked about she's what we're looking to
govern looking for policies looking for
results to go back to these districts
and say we're not just talking about
things were actually passing legislation
that is not getting passed in the Senate
because the mean Republicans won't take
it up AOC in the Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib are interested in the cultural
battle overall they are activists they
don't have to worry about getting
reelected in their districts necessarily
they want to change the narrative as a
whole with the whole country and they're
doing that I mean people are talking
about them the media oxygen is being
taken up by then last week AOC accused
the Border Patrol of forcing illegal
immigrants to drink out of toilets and
that was something that everyone had to
respond to so they're to past year and
I think they're just different at this
point whether Nancy Pelosi will be
victorious right now she is and the
media did a great job following up on
that accusation right we really got to
the bottom of that toilet drinking by
the way I just think that she got four
votes Katie I mean I mean yeah
clearly the the strength of the caucus
the overwhelming majority went with
Polly
Washington that's what I say overall
with the country in Congress right but
there's that you can do both at the same
time you can deal with the overall
narrative and direction of the country
and then you can deal with the impact of
governing well I think Tom era I think
there are a lot of Democrats who want
Pelosi to be more aggressive but you
know what you still don't have to know
how to count the votes